you think about what he said earlier
about guys liking Alpha women sometimes
like certain guys well I found myself
very my mom was an alpha woman she's a
high high income earner compared to my
dad so she actually her career took off
you know in computer science she's got a
master's computer science so when we
moved to Canada she was like the Soviet
engineer and her career took off and my
dad just remained a humble mechanic and
so I found myself at a young age
attracted to these women that were sort
of like argumentative sometimes would
cause a scene in public because that's
my mom and wanted control and I made a
again I I started finding myself
attracted to those women and I remember
my first serious girlfriend for two
years she never cooked a meal she said I
think it's beneath women to cook for men